vous êtes au supermarché vous voyez un
produit à 9 euros mais il a écrit dessus
c'était 15 euros avant il en promotion
vous avez vous dire c'est une bonne
affaire
peut-être que si vous aviez vu le même
produit juste à 9 euros sans la
promotion marque et vous auriez lits
dont 9 euros c'est quand même très cher
quand on vous dit ce produit là qui vaut
9 euros avant il en valait 15
on vous a un petit peu ancrées sur le
chiffre de 15 et vous dites abeilles par
rapport à 15 ans je fais une économie en
fait la question que vous devriez vous
poser c'est est-ce que ce produit j'ai
envie de l'acheter à 9 euros mais le
fait qu'on vous ait 10 15 vous
influencent un petit peu ce qu'on voit
là c'est ce qu'on appelle un biais
cognitifs c'est à dire une déviation par
rapport à ce qui devrait être la réponse
rationnelle de la manière dont on va
réagir
le fait qu'on ait été ancrée sur 15
euros nous fait penser que 9 euros c'est
pas cher ce qu'on nous a appris à
l'école c'est quand on doit prendre une
décision
on recueille les données en les analyses
on les traite on est objectif
opérationnel mais en fait on sait bien
que c'est pas comme ça que ça se passe
quand on doit prendre une décision on a
une idée qui nous vient cette idée elle
nous vient de ce qu'on appelle le
système la pensée rapide la manière
qu'on a dépensé on dit quelquefois
intuitivement ses idées qui nous
viennent et ensuite on va éventuellement
faire l'effort de vérifier ce que le
système 1 nous a suggéré avec ce qu'on
appelle le système 2 la pensée lente et
en fait on va avoir des biais cognitifs
quand on va laisser notre système
souffler très fort la décision est que
le système ne va pas suffisamment la
vérifier
le biais de confirmation c'est le fait
que quand on regarde des informations va
avoir tendance à les filtrer parce qu'on
peut pas prêter attention à toutes les
informations qui sont autour de nous on
serait complètement submergées et donc
on va recommencer à les filtrer d'une
manière bizet qui est de donner plus de
poids aux informations qui confirme ce
qu'on pensait déjà et au contraire de
donner moins d'importance à celles qui
pourraient nous faire changer d'avis un
exemple et vidéo vous regardez un débat
politique entre deux candidats il y en a
un que vous soutenez et on arrive vous
soutenez pas et bien à la fin du débat
vous allez vous dire que celui que vous
soutenez a marqué plus de points que
l'autre est votre copain qui regardaient
le débat avec vous et qui est l'opinion
politique opposée il va penser
exactement le contraire vous avez
regardé le même débat vous avez vu un
débat différent parce que chacun de vous
et est plus attentif au point que
marquer son candidat à lui et à
sincèrement penser que l'autre remarquer
mois
vous êtes cinq copains et vous devez
aller manger au restaurant il faut
choisir quel restaurant et comment vous
allez faire pour décider bien souvent il
y en a un qui va dire à moi j'ai une
super idée j'ai trouvé un resto un resto
italien très bien là on va y aller et
les autres vont dire oui pourquoi pas ok
puis on va tous aller au resto italien
est en fait peut-être que les quatre
autres il n'avait pas du tout envie
d'aller au restaurant italien
ils avaient tous une meilleure idée
peut-être la même d'ailleurs ou
peut-être une idée différente mais
simplement ils sont pas exprimés ça
c'est le piège de la pensée de groupe
c'est que la manière dont on a organisé
la décision ou plutôt la manière dont on
n'a pas organisé on l'a juste laisser
émerger comme ça va faire en sorte que
la première idée ou celle qui a exprimé
le plus fort ou quand il ya une
hiérarchie celle qui est exprimé par le
chef va avoir plus de poids que les
autres et que ceux qui sont en désaccord
vont avoir tendance à étouffer leur
désaccord parce qu'ils veulent pas faire
de vagues
parce qu'ils veulent pas être
enquiquinant et parce qu'ils ne savent
pas qu'ils sont pas seuls à penser que
j'y pense
le biais de disponibilité c'est le fait
que notre système à notre pensée rapide
a tendance à s'attacher aux informations
disponibles simplement parce qu'elles
sont là pas parce que c'est les plus
importantes pas parce qu'on en a besoin
mais parce qu'elles sont disponibles
un exemple de ça qui était frappant
pendant la crise du que vides 19
c'est qu'on n'arrêtait pas de comparer
le nombre de cas entre les différents
pays
alors à chaque fois on disait mais en
fait le nombre de cas il veut rien dire
parce qu'il dépend de la politique de
tests selon qu'on a fait beaucoup de
tests qu'on n'a pas fait beaucoup on va
trouver un nombre de cas complètement
différent et à chaque fois on lui disait
oui oui mais quand même on compare parce
que c'est quand même intéressant de
comparer alors qu'en fait c'est une
comparaison qui veut juste rien dire
c'est un exemple frappant
on prend l'information qui est
disponible au lieu de se demander quelle
est l'information qu'on voudrait
vraiment à voir et d'aller la chercher
alors ce qu'on peut faire de mieux pour
se mettre en alerte contre les biais
c'est demander aux autres de nous aider
c'est demander à ceux qui nous entourent
dans une équipe dans un groupe d'amis
dans une équipe de travail de nous dire
là tu es en train de tomber dans le
piège de l'excès de confiance
tu crois pas moi j'essaye d'appliquer
cette leçon là et de me dire que d'une
part il faut que j'écoute les gens
autour de moi quand ils disent que j'ai
dévié cognitis est pas facile et surtout
d'autre part j'essaye d'avoir une
méthode de décision qui me protège de
mai biais cognitifs la méthode de
décision c'est ce qui va vous permettre
de faire en sorte que quand vous devez
faire un choix
vous allez le faire sur les bons
critères avec les bons outils et pas en
suivant votre instinct qui risque d'être
influencée par des biais cognitifs